we're gonna tackle this guy now again
some of you may look may have be at the
point where you're like i know what that
is
i know what it is um and i'm just gonna
go for it i'm just gonna put it on but
again i'm trying to push on your ability
to geometrically reason
what is going on and i've just reminded
myself that i need to hit record on this
for this next part
[Music]
okay so um what does this
mean i desperately do not want to go to
the algebra on this i mean i can i
should point out but i'd rather not
how do i go about this well the first
thing i want to notice is
it might be more useful to me if i state
this as
a closer relationship or a more direct
relationship i should say
between this argument and this argument
right i've been thinking about it in
moduli
so far but arguments are a little
sneakier as you'll see
so i'm going to just add r of z minus 3
to both sides is that okay
like this is saying the same thing as
that but now this equips
me to think about this in visual terms
more easily
what does this term this whole term here
on the left hand side mean
how would you verbally explain what's
happening
it's an angle for starters right this is
the angle and i'd love you to drop this
down with me right
this is the angle to
our particular moving point z
right the angle measured
2z um i'm just going to imply here you
don't need to write it but it's from
the positive real direction right
because that's always how we measure
angles we always measure anti-clockwise
but when we say arg just regular z
right we know that we're looking at z
from a particular point of view from a
particular reference point
where are we measuring from for just
argument from the origin right so you
start there
bam and then you look to wherever zed is
but this modification right
this here means you're not from the
origin anymore
you're from a different point of
reference namely
minus i right it's the same thing we did
with the modulus i would write this as
in fact i'll do it right now
arg of z take away minus i
so this this is our reference point okay
the angle measure to z
from minus i yes
in exactly the same way this is the
angle measured
2z i'm just going to write dot dot 2z
from where from from 3 which is why i
ask you to plot that
as your reference point okay now to try
and visualize what is going on
here are our same two points right minus
i
and three and what i've plotted on to
there are some
intervals to indicate uh i'm looking
at here's my here's my black spot uh
black spot there
right this is my z as it moves around
okay
and what i'd like you to visualize here
as well is that you've got
you know the positive real direction
here so there's like an angle
implied for the red interval and then
over here you've got another
positive real sort of ray coming out and
you've got another angle
implied okay now if i want these angles
to be
the same as i as i sort of shuffle
this point around right if i want the
angles to be the same
i guess what i'm trying to say is i want
both the blue
and the red intervals to be facing in
the same
direction would you agree with that
right um
for example you can see here they're
sort of vaguely headed in the same
direction but you can see the angle
to the red one it's like in this case
it's a right angle isn't it right
whereas the one to the blue one it's
something i don't know that's like
pi on three or something like that four
is a 45 oh it's four exactly 45 so
pi on four right so these angles these
angles are not the same
i want them to be the same so now i want
you to think again
when we were doing the perpendicular
bisector i asked you to push
hard on your verbal center right how
could you describe
a point or maybe if you want you can try
and give me some coordinates but i
deliberately took them off to make that
part harder
right how would you describe a point
where
the red and the blue intervals are
parallel headed in the same
direction any takers
i might go to mike i might get a yeah go
ahead go ahead yeah
um
hmm now you've you've gone like right to
like
you know you've gone zero to 60 in um in
you know two and a half seconds which is
good i'm going to come to that in a
second
what you just said was there's a line
joining
these two spots right you know a bit
like the interval we did before
this is clearly not a spot that works
though because you can see
the red and the blue things are actually
facing in opposite directions do you see
that am i doing my lines my hands in the
right direction yes they're going in
opposite directions so i don't want
this particular spot but if i go along
this line
say if i keep on moving over to the
other side of
three do you see that
um this is looking better because they
are in fact they're so headed in the
same direction
you can't even see the red line anymore
i mean it's underneath right do you
agree
so whatever the coordinates of that spot
is
are what are the coordinates are this is
a spot that actually satisfies
the angles are the same look they're
headed in the same direction right and i
could keep on going
um any of these spots so long as i
extend off will be accurate there you go
right so long as these two overlap with
each other
then your arguments z plus i z minus
three
they're going to be identical does that
make sense there's another spot i can
i can keep going further in this
direction but where else can i go yeah i
can go the opposite direction right
um i can have oops gotta move this i can
have
the blue one being overlapped there you
can see that in fact this is better
because of the order
i've got here um you can see again
measuring from the right angle
measuring from the blue angle in this
case the principal argument would
actually be
negative for both of these wouldn't it
because you're coming from this side and
you're measuring down that way so it's a
clockwise direction
but again my point is whatever angle
that is they're
equivalent does that make sense okay so
here's the way i would say here's the
language i would use
um we are going to have an interval in
here
right just like we did before please
draw it dotted like we did before
because
that interval is not the actual set of
points i'm after it's not the locus
but it it enables me to see the lucas
right
previously the interval here was
perpendicularly bisected right that's
not what's happening here
this interval is kind of well what
language would you use to describe
what's going on we sort of saw these
points over here right
the interval's kind of being extended i
guess it's like oh it goes off
to infinity right extend it this way
we've just seen you can extend it that
way
as well but right out the gate and i'm
going to put the spot back on there
right
all right right there we saw points on
the interval itself
no good the red and the blue arguments
are facing opposite directions
so in fact we extend this interval but
then we also
exclude it right can i say that again
the first category when we're looking at
modules equals modulus
we took that interval and then we
bisected it at right angles
here what we're doing is we take that
interval and we do two things
we extend and then we exclude right does
that make sense
so we know we're good of that that
direction good off in that direction
this is one teeny thing that we have
left that we haven't addressed
which is um these reference points see
these reference points
are they included in my locus or not
now i see i see giu vigorously shaking
her head
why why aren't these spots included
because
you can't get a number on that spot
because
you don't have a name okay so
you cannot get sure is exactly right
right you can't get an
argument from these spots because as we
looked at in tuesday's lesson right
if i said to you hey zed can move
anywhere what if i moved on to
three itself right what would be the the
actual
value of r z minus three at that spot
and you're in trouble right because
you're like oh i'm on that spot
this is the argument of three
take away three i'm in trouble because
this is arg0 which we said was
undefined right because which direction
are you facing in to look at that spot
the answer is well
any direction it's a bit like standing
at the north pole every direction is
south so like this is useless right
there's no point saying south because
everywhere is south
so we say the same thing for arg 0. so
that's why you can see
you must include this it's really
important your reference points here
3 and negative i they must be
hollow circles okay all right u12 at
this point i'm going to try and take my
own advice we've got more weird and
wonderful shapes to explore
but i'm going to hit pause on them we've
got we've got some time next week as
well
so after i finish here one f which is
the exercise you began on tuesday
you're going to continue into that today
with the time you've got left but
um i want to briefly uh get at what's
what's the equation of this let's what's
the cartesian equation let's close it
off and then i'll let you um
get to work okay so for starters who has
um just the y equals relationship the
equation
for this someone got it
from memory it's it's 1 over 3
1 over 3 x
minus one are you okay with that
in fact this is um a sufficiently easy
you know set of points you could you
literally eyeball that right like when
you think about the gradient
um gradient is just rise sorry rise over
run
rise over run so it's like oh this is
nice because they're on the corner axes
that's one that's three so that gives me
a rise over run of a third
there's x and then the y intercepts a
nice whole number so you're like great
okay this this is not the cartesian
equation
of that set of points because this
is the cartesian equation of this set of
points
and we we strenuously you know pointed
out that we don't include the entire
thing right
so therefore i need to be able to say
something that gets rid
of that part of it what do i say
okay i can say x is going to be less
than zero am i including zero
definitely not because of this hollow
circle which we talked about before
that's only the left-hand side part what
about the other
part x is greater than
three now you'll notice i've left this
kind of gap
in here right now we need to put
something in this gap
and it is important i want you to think
back to the regions you were doing
on tuesday it is important what you put
in here
um it's so important that if you put a
comma
because i don't know what you mean by
that comma
i have to treat that as you don't know
what that comma is supposed to be
so i'm not going to put a comma i'm
going to give you two choices
you've got the word and and you've got
the word
or which one
is it
anyone want to uh here's what i'm gonna
before you say what your answer is
um i want you to raise your hand if you
have an answer in your head
whichever one it is and you're confident
you could tell me why that answer is
what it is
i'm not going to put you on the spot to
tell me what it is but i want to see how
many of you think you know which one
whether it's and or or hands up i see
i see low confidence ratings which is
the information that i wanted
okay interesting i didn't require but
is anyone who thinks they know willing
to share with us which one they think it
is and why
yeah give us a go show you what do you
think i think
i think in this case it's maybe or
because um i think and it means like
they happen at the same time
hmm what are you thinking
about what you just said she correct me
if i'm wrong
you're tentatively putting out an or
because if we had said
and we mean for these inequalities to be
simultaneously satisfied do you agree
it's like and you saw this before if we
were doing regions from
tuesday's lesson you might say oh i want
the region that satisfies um
i don't know say this and also i want it
to satisfy
say i don't know this right
and means i don't just want uh imagining
this i don't i don't just want this part
um and then also include these bits over
here
right uh this part here doesn't
uh did i do this right no sorry i needed
to real part two
i i need a boundary there okay there we
go um
this part here over in this side meets
this
but it does not mean this you're like i
don't want that right so
and was our way of saying give me both
or give me three and four
at the same time but when you think
about what we're saying
here is it possible for a number
to be simultaneously less than zero
and greater than three even with
weird complex numbers and square roots
of negatives i i can't think of a number
that does that right so therefore our
instincts
were right and well done if you did
think of that but it's the reasoning is
the important part and the willingness
to say
well what if i said and like what would
that lead to oh it's a contradiction
that's another one okay that's important
so uh this this with the domain
restriction included
this is the cartesian equation i'm after
if you do not include
the restriction you don't have the right
spots make sense